I'll tell you what would take a while
because and everyone's gonna find out
about this because we're gonna sell
tickets and we're gonna have a
pay-per-view it's gonna be the first
fighter in the kid pay-per-view you're
venturing into new lands and you want to
make some real [ __ ] money yeah yeah
yeah we're gonna do a pay-per-view and
it's gonna be you and me and it's gonna
be we're gonna incorporate a little of
the you know the the wrestling sports
entertainment thing we're gonna say that
it's a No Disqualification match right
but MMA rules No Disqualification and
submission or knockout only and then and
then you're gonna come at me with
whatever what's it going to be now I'm
gonna shock and I'm gonna and I got
considered right and I'm gonna I'm gonna
swap those away and bat my eyes and it's
not gonna be fun to watch right on TV
like he's never fought what the [ __ ]
which is gonna be even more embarrassing
when I actually do get a hold of you and
just kick your legs out from under you
and then I start the game line compress
yeah bring that up chin that game of
thrones scene what's the guy's name out
in the mountains man with hands people
are gonna go get popcorn and hot dogs
cuz it's gonna take about four hours of
me just going and again you're out cold
in the first 30 seconds and then at
around the four hour mark you're just
gonna hear and then you're gonna get
views their laps in the exact I pictures
now you got a fast forward cuz it's
shown the whole scene here we're what
are you gonna do it like outdoors like
that you've gone that the Greek theater
it here in LA yeah I'm us and I'm gonna
sit on top and I'm also gonna rent a
small person to play you know when it
comes gonna sit there like the Emperor
yes and just do the thumbs-up
thumbs-down
yes when it comes to um swordplay there
we go much matter size of the sword
matters so there's Brian with that
shitty bowl cut and then here's will Oh
there goes all your teeth and then
here's will and this will take four
hours with this imagine this for four
hours I gotta watch this show
now here's will doing this and Dad oh
and Dead Game of Thrones style Will
Sasso Brian Cowen oh that's gonna sell
paper views well died though and then he
died yeah yeah you're wait see I'm the
old rich dude that love you know that's
me right there and then we'll rent the
small guy out fine and you dropped that
outfit yeah is that [ __ ] John
Varvatos then we'll hire just some dime
piece yeah look at that quilted was that
quilted armor and yeah see that won't
happen do you be I'm not cool having my
hang enough to fill out some papers
before we start I'll tell you that right
now you might want to get your issues in
order I'm not gonna get your banking in
order I might want to fill it you might
want to get that will going no I'm not
doing it I'm to think about though bro
I'm gonna think about when you see my
back ripple and I pull myself up like a
champ like a champ through 30 times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gif it's a gift
it's a gift